es ist ein urteil das fassungslos macht
gymnasiallehrer holger p hat gestanden
seinen damals zweijährigen sohn sexuell
missbraucht und massen an
kinderpornografie besessen zu haben
das urteil im november zwei jahre und
drei monate haft dann geht der
kinderschänder im berufungsurteil jetzt
bewährung zugeschaltet aus hannover ist
mir mein kollege mirko voltmer motto du
hast den prozess beobachtet hast für uns
recherchiert in dem fall was ist das für
ein mann dieser kinderschänder der jetzt
mit bewährung davon kommt also
grundsätzlich sagen
der mann führte vor bekanntwerden der
taten eigentlich ein bilderbuch leben da
ist er stammt ursprünglich aus dem kreis
minden lübbecke war dort in der kirche
aktiv als organist soziales engagement
leitet die kinderchöre später der
wechsel dann in den raum bückeburg wo er
als gymnasiallehrer dann unterrichtet
hat verheiratet zwei kinder eigentlich
alles was nur von außen wenn ihr
glücklich familien darstellt und dann
kam eben die ermittlungen wegen besitzes
von kinder und jugend pornografischen
schriften und in diesem zusammenhang hat
man tatsächlich ein foto ein einziges
foto unter diesen 30.000 dateien
gefunden bei ihm zu hause bei einer
durchsuchung
auf dem er mit seinem zweijährigen
jungen abgebildet ist auf dem dann auch
sexuelle handlungen zu sehen waren
das zu dieser
währungs strafe die bewehrung auch
gefordert von der staatsanwaltschaft
grundlage dafür ist eine therapie die
der kinderschänder antreten will
angetreten hat und eine hormontherapie
was ist das für eine therapie also man
muss grundsätzlich sagen
pädophilie ist nicht heilbar das heißt
die täter lernen wurde beziehungsweise
was jetzt holger p vor hat in einer
kombinierten strategie
nämlich medikamente und therapie
zu lernen wie sie künftig sage ich mal
kinder aus dem weg gehen können um
weitere wiederholungstaten zu vermeiden
das heißt also wir haben was er jetzt
lernt ist in der verhaltenstherapie sich
zu konditionieren anzupassen auf
warnsignale zu achten und die
therapeutin wenn ihnen dabei helfen eben
wie gesagt künftig rückfälle zu
vermeiden
dazu kommt natürlich jetzt auch die
medikamentöse behandlung er möchte gern
sein trieb reduzieren das bedeutet sein
testosteron spiegel reduzieren wie die
erfolgschancen sind
muss man sehen wenn man so ja in die
nachrichten schaut dann sind die
erfolgschancen eher nicht so hoch denn
viele der täter der täter von
missbrauchen waren ja schon einmal
auffällig wurden auch schon einmal
verurteilt sind also rückfällige täter
bibel denn die staatsanwaltschaft
konkret in diesem fall sicherstellen
dass holger p tatsächlich ja erfolgreich
aus dieser therapie rausgeht und halten
nicht rückfällig wird gibt man da nicht
ein großes risiko ein
das ist eigentlich die hoffnung der
staatsanwaltschaft dass oder auch die
hoffnung der gerichte der justiz dass
die täter eben dann nicht mehr
rückfällig werden also während der
bewährungszeit haben natürlich all die
justiz ein auge drauf kann zum beispiel
nachweise fordern gerade was die
therapien betrifft kann sich mit
rücksprache von ärzten darüber
unterhalten wie läuft es denn jetzt na
also letztendlich stehen die ärzte dabei
also die meinung der rcz ist hier
maßgeblich den staatsanwalt ist kein
arzt kein mediziner kann es nicht
beurteilen er ist darauf angewiesen
wie die mediziner diesen man einschätzen
und daraufhin wird dann entschieden wie
dann weiter zu verfahren ist
mirko voltmer ganz herzlichen dank für
diese einschätzung ja ein
ein urteil das fassungslos macht in
dieser gemengelage jetzt mit dem fall
aus münster und jetzt halt für diesen
gymnasiallehrer bewährung eine
bewährungsstrafe nachdem er sein damals
zweijährigen sohn vergewaltigt hat